liebe freunde von wismar dieses video
wird etwas besonderes denn wir werden
über die rüstungsindustrie sprechen ein
sehr kontroverses thema bei dem ist sehr
leicht ist es ersatzteile videos zu
drehen in denen jede menge empörung
erzeugt wird um dann haufenweise tricks
zu bekommen einige werden vielleicht
denken dass wir mit diesem thema werbung
für das militär machen oder was genau
gegenteil aber wir tun nur das was über
visa politik immer tun wir zeigen euch
die fakten damit ihr euch dann eure
eigene meinung bilden können sagt ihr
dazu bereit gut dann können wir jetzt
fortfahren
[Applaus]
[Musik]
die usa verfügen über die größte armee
der welt aber das wisst er bereits über
ihr euch wahrscheinlich nicht wirklich
klar sei es die gigantisch diese armee
wirklich ist um sie in relation zu
setzen das weiße haus gibt jedes jahr
mehr für verteidigung aus als das
gesamte bruttoinlandsprodukt polens
beträgt
okay vielleicht hat euch das noch nicht
umgehauen weil die relationen nicht
sofort einleuchtet aber reflektiert das
bitte noch mal für einen moment polen
ist eine komplette mittlerweile recht
wohlhabende und wirtschaftlich
leistungsfähige nation mit rund 40
millionen einwohner
diese 40 millionen menschen haben im
jahr 2009 10 waren und leistungen
arbeitet und konsumiert deren wert sich
auf rund 560 milliarden dollar summiert
und wir haben es desselben jahres haben
die streitkräfte der usa
diese kannst du der riesensumme
aufgezehrt und das ist noch nicht mal
gereicht denn schließlich kostete die
armee den amerikanische steuerzahler im
jahr 2019 sogar 650 milliarden dollar
also sogar 90 milliarden dollar mehr als
alle polen zusammen in diesem jahr
erwirtschafteten verbraucht haben so und
das gilt natürlich nicht nur für 2009/10
sondern für jedes jahr
lasst mich dies noch anders
veranschaulichen minute für minute war
pulver die us armee rund eine million
und 250.000 us dollar das sind pro
stunde 74 millionen oder rund 1,8
milliarden dollar pro tag heute 1,8
milliarden morgen 1,8 milliarden
übermorgen wieder 1,8 milliarden schon
so weiter und so fort ohne pause ohne
ende tag für tag
[Musik]
ja so ausdauernd und schnell geld zu
verbrennen muss man erst einmal schaffen
da würde sogar kanye west den
verdächtigen und alle ihre plastik lohne
zusammengenommen nach ein paar stunden
bedingungslos spekulieren und falls euch
das immer noch nicht von den socken haut
wird euch noch folgendes aktie hat mit
einer 4 mal so großen bevölkerung die
zweitgrößte armee der welt aber gibt für
diese weniger als ein viertel des
betrags aus den usa gut ihr fragt euch
jetzt vielleicht wohin dieses ganze geld
eigentlich verschwindet die wahrheit ist
nunmal dass die verteidigung der heimat
keine billiges geschäft ist zum beispiel
kostet ein panzer wie der m1 r bremst
ihr sehen könnt 6 millionen dollar
aber moment panzer zählen in dieser
branche nämlich zum will ich spielzeug
wenn man einen hochmodernen kampfjets
f-35 käuflich erwerben möchte kostet das
einen mindestens 100 millionen dollar
aber es geht nicht darum panzer und
kampfjets es gibt ja noch die ganzen
soldat überleg mal was ein soldat der
auf einer amerikanischen militärbasis
liegt alles kostet moderne tarnkleidung
macht sich brillen und die bewaffnung
was meint ihr wie viel kostet all das
was ein soldat mit sich herumträgt 1000
dollar 2000 dollar
auch jetzt hat man nicht so zimperlich
ist halte ich fest die ausrüstung für
einen normalen durchschnittlichen
soldaten der us army ist 10.000 us
dollar wert und es wagst du dich
vielleicht ist das denn normal geben
andere länder auch sophie armeen aus nun
um einen vergleich zu ziehen trägt ein
soldat in marokko nur 500 bis 1000
dollar an seinem gestählten körper wie
ihr sehen könnt haben wir es hier mit
einer ordentlich großen industrie zu tun
[Musik]
eine industrie die mehr als 1,5
millionen menschen beschäftigt einige
davon arbeiten direkt bei der armee und
einige arbeiten für die vielen vielen
unternehmen welche die armee mit waffen
und allem anderen versorgen was sie so
braucht und ja für viele ist das ein
großartiges geschäft unsere große frage
heute lautet also braucht amerika
wirklich eine so teure armee
letztendlich befindet sich amerika jetzt
nicht mehr im krieg mit einer großmacht
sollten sie ihr geld nicht für etwas
anderes ausgeben die zum beispiel
gesundheitsfürsorge bildung oder einfach
nur die steuern senken wer profitiert am
meisten vom geschäfts mit den militärs
heute werden wir alle diese fragen
beantworten aber bevor wir dies tun
lasst uns die immer einen blick zurück
in die geschichte werfen
[Musik]
viele von euch denken vielleicht dass
die amis schon immer verrückt waren nach
ihrem militär aber die wahrheit ist in
der tat nominierten in der ersten hälfte
des neunzehnten jahrhunderts
privatarmeen das verteidigungsgeschäft
in amerika geschäftsleute hörten söldner
an um ihren besitz gegen indiana zu
schützen und das weiße haus fühlte sich
damals ziemlich sicher auf seinem
kontinent schließlich genossen die usa
natürlichen schutz durch den klang blick
auf der einen und den pazifik auf der
anderen seite keine invasionsarmee
konnte diese großen teiche so schnell
überbrückten wozu sollte man da starke
boden streitkräfte unterhalten und dann
kommt der erste mann unserer geschichte
ins spiel
[Musik]
amerikaner müssen nun beginnen nach
außen zuschauen
die wachsende produktion des landes
verlangt es helfe obmann der
amerikanischen armee während des ions
krieges mayhem entwickelte eine
politische theorie die verlangte dass
die usa zu einer führenden streitmacht
auf den ozeanen werden müssen um die
neuralgischen punkte des welthandels
unter ihre kontrolle zu bringen jene
nadelöhre auf hoher see an denen man den
internationalen warenströmen den hahn ab
oder auftreten kann
der plan war dass die usa auf diese
weise leicht zu einer supermacht werden
könnten diese in der zweiten hälfte des
neunzehnten jahrhunderts noch nicht mal
im ansatz war am und von da an begann
das weiße haus eine große marine
streitmacht aufzubauen zunächst aber nur
diese ja die usa waren eines der ersten
länder mit zb flugzeugträgern und
anderen innovativen see waffen aber ihre
landstreitkräfte waren auch lange nicht
besonders beeindruckend zu ende des
zweiten weltkriegs entwickelten die usa
dann auch noch eine unglaublich
bahnbrechende waffe die atombombe
nun dachten sie dies sei doch grund
genug damit andere länder sie gebührend
respektierten
wer würde es schließlich wagen ein land
anzugreifen welches eine feine per
knopfdruck in atommüll verwandeln kann
nun diese phase hielt nur äußerst kurz
an und schon in den 50er jahren singt
die dinge an sich dramatisch zu ändern
24 juni 1950 beamte des
außenministeriums sagte am samstagabend
dass die vereinigten staaten russland
für den kommunistischen angriff
nordkoreas auf die unabhängige
südkoreanische republik verantwortlich
machen werden
der korea krieg hat begonnen und dies
war ein wendepunkt in der amerikanischen
der geschichte plötzlich erfuhr das
weiße haus das die sowjets einigen so
mächtig aber nicht sogar stärkere wale
waren als sie sie hat und letztlich auch
atombomben und eine gut ausgebildete
armee die amerikaner bekam während der
ersten schlachten in korea ordentlich
den hintern also und dies war eine klare
ansage an washington wenn man uns in
korea besiegen kann
könntet uns das gleiche nicht auch zum
beispiel in kalifornien wieder fahren ja
meine lieben zuschauer dies war der
moment in dem präsident eisenhower die
militärdoktrin seines landes für immer
änderte das war der beginn der
[Musik]
abschreckung
ihr werdet vielleicht überrascht sein
aber während weltkriegs kämpften einige
armee noch zugpferd und mit schwertern
damals ging es in kriegen um strategie
und eine große zahl von soldaten die vor
ort gegeneinander kämpften technologie
diesem beispiel die luftwaffe spielte
nur eine untergeordnete rolle
sie war es war faszinierend aber
weitgehend wirkungslos für den ausgang
des krieges all dies änderte sich
während des zweiten weltkriegs die
deutschen v2 raketen waren ein totaler
technologischer spielverderber er ist
den deutschen ermöglichte london aus
hunderten von kilometern entfernung zu
bombardieren ganz ohne große
truppenkontingente diese wirkung hatte
das manhattan project bei der
entwicklung der atombombe waren mehr
wissenschaftler als soldaten zugang so
hat sich das spiel für immer verändert
es ging nicht mehr darum der die meisten
soldaten aufbieten stattdessen ging es
darum wer die beste technologie rdx und
eisenhower war der erste amerikanische
präsident der dies könnte
wir waren gezwungen eine permanente
rüstungsindustrie gewaltigen ausmaßes zu
schaffen hinzu kommt dass dreieinhalb
millionen männer und frauen direkt im
verteidigungssektor beschäftigt sind wir
geben jährlich allein für die
militärische sicherheit mehr aus als die
summe der reingewinn aller unternehmen
in den vereinigten staaten abschiedsrede
von präsident dwight eisenhower
ironischerweise warnte der präsident in
dieser abschiedsrede seine nachfolge
vor dem potenziellen risiken dem so
hohen militärausgaben verbunden sind
aber es war zu spät das wettrüsten hatte
bereits begonnen und damit auch eine
ganz neue lehre die abschreckungs
theorie abstecken ergreifung oder
androhung von maßnahmen mit dem ziel
jemanden von bestimmten nicht
gewünschten handlungen abzuhalten okay
okay aber lass mich erklären was das
wirklich bedeutet ich möchte euch ein
kleines beispiel sei was ihr hier seht
ist eine spitfire ein jagdflugzeug der
britischen royal air force aus dem
zweiten weltkrieg die spitfires wurden
in eine automobilfabrik hergestellt die
während des krieges in eine militärische
waffenschmiede umgewandelt wurde dieser
umbau wusste so schnell wie möglich
vonstatten gehen also wurde für die
herstellung der meisten teile
einschließlich des rumpfes nach
möglichkeit dass verwendet was bereits
in der autofabrik vorhanden war also
schrauben und andere bauteile aus der
automobilfertigung
dieser hier ist eine es 86 die nur zehn
jahre später gebaut wurde
wir sprechen hier von einem jet der
schneller als der schall fliegen kann
dafür braucht man schon einen speziellen
rum den nicht einfach ein kfz mechaniker
mit hammer und schraubendreher
zusammenklappen kann alle komponenten
dieses kleinen kunstwerks müssen dass
man einen dedizierten auf
militärtechnologie spezialisierten team
hergestellt werden und was bedeutet das
im endeffekt es bedeutet vor allem dass
man früher leicht zivile
fertigungsanlagen in waffenfabriken
umwandeln konnte tja und heute alter
vergisst wenn man seine feinde
ordentlich abspecken will muss man sich
zu jedem zeitpunkt einen technologischen
vorsprung bewahren und dafür muss man
auch in friedenszeiten ständig in die
rüstung investieren diese technologie
investitionen waren auch schon der
ursprung so manchen zivile technologie
booms in einem anderen video erzählen
wir euch darüber wie das israelische
militär seine bilanz dazu verhallt eine
hightech nation zu werden und auch das
silicon valley begann als militärischer
forschungskomplex aber moment mal denn
diese abschreckung sache geht weit
darüber hinaus seht euch mal folgendes
[Musik]
ewiger krieg zu beginnen dieses videos
haben wir euch davon erzählt dass ein
durchschnittlicher amerikanischer soldat
mehr als 10.000 dollar an modernster
ausrüstung mit sich herumträgt ich weiß
dass viele von euch in diesem moment
dachten wer es nicht cool das alles mal
auszuprobieren gut natürlich niemand
markt krieg aber hey all diese
faszinierenden dinge mal auszuprobieren
das muss doch interessant sein oder ja
in wirklichkeit würde er aber du nicht
mal wissen wo er anfangen sollte jeder
soldat muss die steuerung einer drohne
beherrschen modernste technologie nutzen
können und ein funkgerät für
verschlüsselte nachrichten blieben
können und ich kann euch verraten das
alles ist nicht leicht zu erlernen eine
langjährige ausbildung ist so gute
voraussetzung welche folgen hat das also
alles vor allem das ende der wehrpflicht
während des zweiten weltkriegs mussten
die meisten jungen amerikanischen männer
an der front kämpfen ein paar monate
training und auf in den kampf nach dem
krieg wurden dann alle diese soldaten
zurück in ihre heimat geschickt damit
sie ihr bürgerliches leben weiterleben
konnten
dies ist heute im grunde undenkbar
glaubt ihr etwa das die wehrpflicht in
vielen ländern aus rein ethischen
gründen abgeschafft wurde weil die
politiker plötzlich anfängen die
individuelle freiheit ihrer bürger zu
priorisieren pustekuchen eine
berufsarmee ist notwendig damit ein land
permanent über eine ausreichende zahl
von soldaten verfügt deren ausbildung
dem technischen stand heutiger
kriegsführung entspricht
und das ganz unabhängig davon ob es sich
gerade im krieg befindet oder im frieden
denn wenn ein krieg plötzlich
hereinbrechende ein land ohne
berufsarmee heutzutage keine chance mehr
genug kämpfer aus dem stand heraus
auszubilden die eben einer guten
berufsarmee auf feinde seite paroli
bieten würden aber genug der theorie ich
weiß was ihr sehen wollt beispiele aus
der realität die beweisen dass sich all
diese ausbildung all diese investitionen
ins militärische humankapital auch
tatsächlich auszahlen okay hier kommen
sie
[Musik]
die größte armee der welt wir schreiben
den zweiten august 1990 die usa erklären
saddam husseins irak den krieg weil
diese in kuwait einem wichtigen
amerikanischen verbündeten eingefallen
war so begann der golfkrieg die ihr
wisst haben die usa diesen krieg
gewonnen aber die große überraschung war
wie diesen krieg gewonnen haben auf 300
gefallen iraker kamen gerade mal ein
gefallener us soldat das war nicht nur
ein sieg das war ein triumph eine
regelrechte militär parade die sich nur
durch eines erklären lässt mindestens
zehn jahre techno geschafft worden
[Musik]
und womit stellen die usa sicher dass
sie zu jeder zeit über die absolute
technologische überlegenheit verfügen
natürlich mit hilfe des so genannten
militärisch industriellen komplexes
dabei handelt es sich um den
partnerschaftlichen zusammenschluss
zwischen der regierung und privaten
unternehmen nehmen wir zum beispiel dass
es 35 projekte im jahr 1992
veröffentlichte das weiße haus eine
öffentliche ausschreibung zur
neuentwicklung ihres märz verkauft
viele unternehmen schickten ihre
angebote und projekte ein und
schließlich wurde der gewinner
bekanntgegeben lockheed martin
28 jahre später wird die f35 endlich in
jährige fertigt heute haben die usa
damit den besten kampf täter welt
russland oder china können mit dieser
beeindruckenden technologischen
leistungen einfach nicht mithalten
aber wie wir bereits gesagt haben kostet
jedes dieser spielzeuge mehr als 100
millionen dollar
und bei solche summen fragen sich
natürlich einige von euch was dazu
eigentlich der us-finanzminister sagt
der muss bei solch exorbitanten ausgaben
durch ganz schöne bauchschmerzen
bekommen oder nun im grunde eigentlich
nichts denn hier kommt der clou 2018
kamen die ersten einsatzfähigen es 35
jetzt auf den markt und nur ein jahr
später konnten wir in den nachrichten
schon meldungen wie die folgende seite
norwegen ist dem f 35 programm
beigetreten im november 2008 wählte die
norwegische regierung die f35 als ersatz
für die f16 flotte aus die amerikanische
militär industrie ist auch eine der
größten exportbranchen der usa mit
anderen worten angriffs m gibt jährlich
650 milliarden dollar für die
verteidigung aus der größte teil dieses
geldes fließt in die bezahlung der
beamten muss soldaten gehälter in die
instandhaltung der anlagen und im kauf
von waffensystemen aber wie viel
verdienen die usa mit dem export ihrer
waffen einige schätzungen besagen dass
im jahr 2019 mehr als 400 milliarden
dollar eingenommen halten und was
passiert mit altem material was passiert
mit den alten amerikanischen kampfjets
in einigen fällen werden sie einfach
irgendwo eingemottet aber in vielen
fällen passiert so etwas
usa genehmigen den verkauf und die
modernisierung von marokkanischen f 16
flugzeugen für 4,8 milliarden dollar und
ich weiß was du denkst kommt schon mal
erst erzählst du uns davon wie die usa
unmengen an geld ausgeben um die
technologische überlegenheit zu behalten
und dann erzählst du dass sie eben diese
überlegene technologie einfach so an
andere länder verhökern
verlieren sie dadurch nicht ihren ganzen
vorsprung wieder einmal lautet die
antwort ja und nein
schaut der wochenmarkt ist nur in
seltenen fällen ein freier markt jedes
mal wenn ein us-unternehmen jets panzer
oder was auch immer in ein anderes land
verkaufen will muss der kongress die
transaktion genehmigen das bedeutet dass
die usa waffen nur an ihrer verbündeten
verkaufen und dieser mechanismus kann
eine verdammt starke politische waffe
darstellen hier ist ein beispiel amerika
und marokko sind seit dem achtzehnten
jahrhundert enge verbündete
warum nun das ist eine schöne geschichte
für ein weiteres video für heute
verraten durch nur dass amerika und
marokko gute freunde sind und als in den
1970 er jahren marokko in die westsahara
eindrang
die damals noch eine spanische kolonie
wollte spanien seine kolonie natürlich
mit seinen kanzler verteidigen und o
moment mal sagte ich eben seinen panzern
in einer mine auf all diesen tanz lang
lebte noch ein etikett und auf dem
prangte made in die usa auf echt was
also denkst du hat washington zu alldem
gesagt wahrscheinlich so etwas in dieser
art hey alter was ist los spanien kann
man hier über zu kleine wenn ich sehe
dass du mit meinen tänzern gegen meinen
marokkanischen freund kämpft dann wird's
kein gutes ende mit dir nehmen ein
freund und hey warte hier geblieben ich
bin noch nicht fertig mit dir
falls du nur eine sekunde darüber
nachdenkst meine panzer hinter meinem
rücken zu benutzen denkt daran dass ich
der einzige bin der dir diese person
reparieren und auch neue munition und
ersatzteile liefern kann
verstehst okay dann kannst du jetzt
wieder gehen und mit einer siesta
weitermachen oder was
wieder einmal treibst gut das alles
schon 50 jahre her aber wenn ihr dachtet
dass dieser politische druck der
vergangenheit angehört dann solltet ihr
noch einmal nachdenken und euch ansehen
was gerade in norwegen los ist
pionieren die f35 jets sind sensible
norwegische militärdaten an lockheed
martin in den vereinigten staaten
tja wenn wir über waffen sprechen sie
ist das thema freier markt
globalisierung und so weiter wie ein
ziemlicher witz aus das nationale
interesse steht an erster stelle aber
diese geschichte hört hier noch nicht
auf wie du dir vorstellen kannst steht
der amerikanische kongress unter enormen
druck immer mehr für das militär
auszugeben denkt mal darüber nach
wir reden hier von mehr als 1,5
millionen wählern und ihren familien die
damit ihren lebensunterhalt bestreiten
wenn wir uns zum beispiel dass es 35
projekt anschauen ist dies nicht nur ein
riesiger gewinnbringer für loch mit
makeln daran hängen auch tausende von
arbeitsplätzen in den texanischen werken
von logport und dies stellt auch eine
politische waffe
[Musik]
wer bezahlt bestimmt auch die musik in
diesem fall vor allem wo die musik
spielt stell dir vor du bist ein
kongressabgeordneter aus texas und kann
dies über allen das beste dass du deinen
wählern sagen kannst ist hallo leute
die neue f 35 wird natürlich in texas
gebaut in einer nagelneuen fabrik in der
1000 hoch qualifizierte arbeiter arbeit
finden und ein gutes gehalt bekommen
werden und ihr braucht mir wirklich
nicht dafür zu danken mit anderen worten
die lobbyisten des militärisch
industriellen komplexes haben in den usa
eine extrem starke position ihr sprechen
hierbei nicht nur über fragen der
weltpolitik sondern auch über
arbeitsplätze und wählerstimmen und das
erklärt warum die eisenhower
abschiedsrede heute noch genauso aktuell
ist wie damals als sie gehalten wurde in
den regierungs ausschüssen müssen wir
uns vor ungerechtfertigter einflussnahme
durch den militärisch industriellen
komplex ob gewollt oder ungewollt
schützen
die gefahr eines katastrophalen anstiegs
vollmacht an den falschen stellen ist
real und wird weiterbestehen
abschiedsrede von präsident dwight
eisenhower und jetzt kommt die frage an
euch glaubt ihr dass amerika zu viel für
sein militär aus gips oder haltet ihr es
wichtig im rüstungswettlauf unbedingt an
erster stelle zu stehen wir freuen uns
wie immer auf eure extrem klugen und vor
weisheit straßenbeiträge im
kommentarbereich und wisst ihr
eigentlich dass wir jede woche neue
frische und informative videos für euch
vorbereitet und veröffentlichen wenn ihr
also keines dieser aktuellen updates
verpassen wollt abonniert bitte visual
politik und drückt danach auch auf die
klingel taste wenn euch dieses video
gefallen hat gebt uns auch einen daumen
hoch bis zum nächsten mal
[Musik]